[Music]
hey guys what's up so today we will be
discussing a topic that has been in our
minds ever since the first master verse
movie came out in 2014 and that is why
it's Godzilla on our side and helping us
against other tyrants instead of just
destroying everything else like the
earlier show of versions in 2014 he
battled and killed the two morose and in
2019 he bailed and later vaporized his
greatest rival which is King Ghidorah
it could be that unlike other Japanese
movies where Godzilla is portrayed as an
evil incarnation of the nuclear bombings
and a monster that destroys everything
in his path or unlike the versions where
he is actually a good guy and protects
humanity from extraterrestrial threats
this most of us Godzilla like the
Tristar Godzilla is portrayed as an apex
predator and a territorial species but
unlike the Tristar Godzilla who only
wants fish the most of us Titanes Gojira
has a high level of intelligence and
also actually knows who the good guys
are and which ones are just collateral
damage it was evident when he appeared
in Castle Bravo the underwater fortress
almost seemingly signaling to the humans
that their species have been tampering
with a grievous trap and that they
should follow him in order to help him
in this battle it was also likely that
he viewed humans as a potential ally and
our pets like Serizawa stated in the
2019 movie and if you remember in the
2014 scene when God's er was about to
hit the United States Navy frigate but
dive to avoid hitting it and also the
scenes where he just ignored the missile
and tank fire on him not treating us
humans like a threat anyway let's put
all these into points and discuss why
Godzilla sees us as allies and potential
friends rather than a species that he
should annihilate so here we go number
one
Godzilla doesn't really see humans as a
threat to his survival but as a source
of radiation we humans have been
drilling and mining on a large scale
since the 19th century and since the mid
20th century for radioactive uranium
resources
so therefore in the eyes of the g-man we
could be reversing the environment to
his liking this might seem strange to
many of you but remember that Godzilla
species evolved during a time when the
Earth's atmosphere and the entire planet
as a whole was more radioactive during
the Permian Triassic age so it is in his
best interest that we should be doing
what we are doing and never stopped
doing it
number two humans are an integral part
of the balance of life and therefore
under his projection it was stated in
the movie that Godzilla was a territory
apex predator that eliminates threats
that upset the balance of the world and
a balance of life and even if we try to
deny and feel that we are above all that
and the natural system which we are not
we still are a part of the ecology of
this world and maybe just maybe us
releasing all the co2 into the
atmosphere might just be another part of
the carbon cycle like recirculating the
trapped carbon so since we are part of
this world we wouldn't be harmed by the
g-man number three since humans have
worshiped Godzilla and Mothra for ages
they seem like another species that
share a symbiotic relationship in king
of the mosses movie we saw that Mothra
and Godzilla each had a temple of their
own even though the people that built
them do not exist anymore
it can be seen that the tyrants were
revered and there was a peaceful and
harmonious existence between these three
species which has Godzilla Mothra and
ancient humanity which could have
developed into a three-way symbiotic
relationship with each species looking
out for each other
number 4 humans might have helped to
battle ancient titans and treads to
Godzilla it has been seen that Ghidorah
in the past have killed a lot of people
which can be seen in the cave paintings
in the post-credits scenes of Kong Skull
Island and also when dr. Chen showed
mana her research on the origins of
Godzilla in king of the mosses movie the
theory is that since humanity has
worshiped and lived alongside mother and
Godzilla they might have also assisted
the two tyrants in the battle against
the monster zero
in the past another theory that I'm just
throwing out there is that humans might
have helped take it out dispose of muta
Prime from Godzilla in the past if a
battle between them ever turned sour for
the g-man and number five
ever since 1954 humans have been
assisting Godzilla in his fight against
the other tyrants
even though modern humanity doesn't see
Godzilla in the same light as the
ancient ones he might not have changed
his view nonetheless humans have been
helping the g-man and killing his foes
although sometimes unknowingly he want
me to list them out alrighty then
in Godzilla awakening in 1954 with the
detonation of the hydrogen bomb in the
Pacific Islands of Bikini Atoll which
was actually aimed at eliminating both
monsters which is Godzilla and XI Nomura
the explosion succeeded in killing one
of the Shi Nomura swamps and also
helping Godzilla since the blast would
have made him more powerful killing the
XI Nomura swamp more easily if you want
another example then look no further
than a 2014 movie when humans also aided
Godzilla in battling and killing both
the male and female mirros in the San
Francisco area if the nest wasn't
destroyed the two bureaus wouldn't have
been distracted and would have got any
of their beatdown on the king in
Godzilla aftershock during her battle
with Godzilla muta Prime releases a
sonic roar so powerful that had
shattered some of his dorsal blades she
does got the upper hand and almost
injected his pose until Emma Russell and
talk and rush into the bunker and
activated a device at blazes sonic
pulses which effectively distracts prime
therefore allowing Godzilla to retaliate
and with an atomic pulse killing him in
king of the monsters humans revived
Godzilla and fought alongside him
against Ghidorah so yeah he was down for
the count due to the oxygen destroyer
weapon in the first place but
nevertheless they revived him and made
him more powerful than ever to a point
that he went thermonuclear due to the
overload of radiation and the essence of
Mothra
by restating point number three that it
takes godzilla mothra
and humans as trees symbiotes to defeat
any threat and so with this we come to
the end of the video and we hope you
enjoyed it
so do like share and subscribe for more
related content and do smash that
notification bell for regular
notifications as well
[Music]